Guten Morgen. Guten Morgen Tim.
Raketenmänner, Hundegebell, äh irgendwie machen wir glaube ich alles falsch in unserer Öffentlichkeitsarbeit. Wir müssen jetzt irgendwie auch mit irgendwas Tuttley out Rages äh raushauen und dann und dann äh wenn endlich alle auf unseren Podcast aufmerksam werden.
Okay, hiermit drohen wir der CDU mit dem Cyber-Erstschlag.
Logbuch Netzpolitik. Zweihundertdreißig, irgendwas mit dreiundzwanzig.
Einundzwanzigster September.
Daran hast du gedacht, was stimm.
Sollen wir ja machen.
Die letzte Sendung definitiv die letzte Sendung von dieser Bundestagswahl, vielleicht auch vor der letzten Bundestagswahl, die wir jemals erleben werden, wer weiß? Äh und alle drehen durch und ähm.
Auch mein meine Autotechnik heute hier. Es ist alles nicht mehr schön und feierlich. Ja, aber so äh schlägt man sich durch und.
Schlagsasse, ja?
Erstschlag.
Okay. Meinst du, dass das bringt dich schon ausreichend außer außer Fassung.
Weiß ich nicht, vielleicht müssen wir noch irgendwie ein paar historische Vergleiche machen.
Wir löschen alle verbotenen Filme von euren.
Wir die die CDU entsorgen wir auf dem Müllhaufen der Geschichte. So.
Ich weiß nicht, ist denn die CDU das Hauptproblem.
Nein, alle anderen auch. Lügenpresse.
Ich sehe schon, wir taugen nicht zum Populisten.
Doch, doch, wir haben äh wir haben Kritik bekommen oder ich habe Kritik bekommen.
Ernsthaft? Ein bisschen.
Ein bisschen. Ja, da wurde gesagt, man möge sich doch mit der äh AfD argumentativ auseinandersetzen. Ähm, mein alle, mein einziger Punkt ist, äh, einer argumentativen Auseinandersetzung ähm,
Verwehrt sich die AfD ja? Also irgendwann ist es ja vorbei. Aber es gibt ein, es ist ein altes Thema,
das sehr schön also was auch immer wieder neu diskutiert werden kann, wo ich auch keine abschließende Meinung habe, ist die Frage mit Nazis reden. Das ist eine sehr schöne, gibt's einen sehr schönen Sketch von Weekloft Roste,
Wenn du Text nicht Sketch-Text, wie Glas Droste schreibt ja immer sehr schön. Sehr schön und böse. Ja.
Wir verlinken jetzt oder den du auswendig zitieren wirst.
Wie alt der ist und ob wir den äh gefahrlos ans Ende der Sendung anwenden kö.
Na, also also ich denke mit der AfD reden,
hilft wirklich nix. Ja, also das ist Blödsinn, aber mit den potenziellen Wählern der AfD reden, das scheint mir sehr angemessen zu sein. Ich kenne nur sehr wenige.
Das ist halt ein Problem meiner Blase. Die ist weitgehend afD frei, soweit ich das zumindest.
Gedanken sind frei. Freies Land.
Ja, das kann natürlich alles sein, also zumindest hat sich mir gegenüber noch keiner geoutet. So,
aber das kann auch sein, dass solche Leute vielleicht automatisch Abstand halten zu mir. Ich weiß es doch auch nicht. Aber wer sozusagen so Leute im Umfeld hat und
den Kommentaren hatten wir ja auch solche Kommentare mit Leute, die so so Leute im Umfeld haben und äh
da wiederum kann man, glaube ich, was erreichen, ne.
Es gibt in den äh Dave Remmel hat äh kommentiert. Ähm ich lässe nicht den ganzen Kommentar vor, aber da hat er net, also er trifft einen Kerl und sagt ähm ich kenne
Viele Sympathisanten der AfD und nein, das sind keine Nazis, sondern,
ganz Liebe und teilweise relativ aufgeklärte Personen. Viele haben einfach Angst, Angst vor Neuen, Angst vor Veränderung, Angst vor den sozialen Abstieg und,
Angst vor Dingen, die sie nicht verstehen. Ja,
Diese Angst habe ich auch. Ähm gegen Angst vor Dingen, die ich nicht verstehe, Angst vor sozialem Abstieg, Angst vor Veränderungen.
Ja, lest euch doch mal das Parteiprogramm von der AfD vor, da solltet ihr es dann aber auch wirklich mit der Angst bekommen, ne?
Weil die Leute, die also aus Angst jetzt da quasi die Selbstmordpartei wählen, die äh ja, das, das wird euch das ist nicht die Agenda, die euch äh voranbringt. Und das ist ein bisschen wie bei Trump glaube ich auch.
Teilweise wissen die Leute das auch? Ja,
Also sie wählen ganz bewusst etwas, was eigentlich gar nicht in ihrem Interesse ist und die Motivation ist eine ganz andere. Motivation ist,
quasi so 'n Hilferuf abzuwerfen und da Sie quasi kein anderen Zugang zu diesem politischen System finden als 'ne Wahl,
Beteiligung durchzuführen
ist das sozusagen ihr Schreckmoment so? Guckt mal, wenn ihr nicht auf uns hört, dann wählen wir sogar Leute, die äh richtig bekloppt und richtig doof und richtig laut sind und die finden wir eigentlich gar nicht so gut, aber wenn man jetzt hier irgendwie
Grün oder Links oder FDP oder CDU wählen, dann ändert sich doch sowieso nichts
das ist so glaube ich so ein bisschen diese Denkrichtung, die an der Stelle greift.
Ich würde gerne nochmal kurz auf diesen Moment der Angst eingehen. Ähm,
also zu Angst mal prinzipiell, ne? Angst ist ein sehr,
Großer Faktor für Menschen ist richtig, also wir haben es evolutionär auch gut, dass wir Angst haben, weil Angst hilft uns, Gefahr zu vermeiden, ne, wenn wir etwas fürchten, dann meiden wir es.
Aber Angst ist in in vielen, vielen Momenten unseres Lebens, insbesondere in der Politik 'ne unglaublich falsche Ratgeber, denn die meisten Ängste sind irrational und durch Verstehen,
baut man die Angst ab, ja? Also wer auf Angst, egal wovor mit Vermeidungsverhalten reagiert,
der wird größere Angst bekommen. Wer sich aber mit den Dingen auseinandersetzt und seinen Ängsten.
Sich mit dem, was er fürchtet, auseinandersetzt, der wird in der Regel weniger Angst bekommen,
Also das kann man übersetzen auf was weiß ich Höhenangst ja? Ich mein wenn du niemals,
niemals dich dich auf einen hohen Turm bekippst, dann wirst du diese Höhenangst auch nicht loswerden, ne? Also Idee der,
Konfrontationstherapie, die übrigens nicht darauf basiert, dass man irgendwie so viel Angst hat, dass man's irgendwann einfach übersteht, sondern dass man
Irgendwann lernt, dass diese Angst einfach Unsinn ist und dass es Unsinn ist, sie zu meiden, sondern dass es sinnvoll ist, sich damit auseinanderzusetzen. Und wer auf Dinge, die er nicht versteht, mit Angst reagiert, das ist völlig normal
Und das Wichtige ist, das zu erkennen und diese Dinge dann zu verstehen. Also Verständnis ist das, was Angst abbaut. Und deswegen darf Angst,
nirgendwo in keinem Zusammenhang unser primärer Ratgeber sein,
Ziel muss immer sein, Angst abzubauen und das dieser Weg führt darüber, Dinge zu verstehen.
Genau, also nächstes Mal nicht Mallorca buchen, sondern vielleicht mal nach Ägypten fahren oder was weiß ich.
Dinge, Dinge, also ich mache das tatsächlich. Ich habe auch vor allem möglichen Angst. Ganz ehrlich und das sind die Sachen, wo ich sofort erkenne, okay, das muss damit musst du dich jetzt auseinandersetzen, das musst du jetzt mal machen,
Ich bin Bungee gesprungen, Alter, ich ich habe heute noch Witze dann heute noch die Knie. Aber ich weiß, dass es geht.
Der man so eine gewisse Wahrscheinlichkeit gibt, dass man's überlebt.
Ich würde es nicht nur bar machen, aber ähm.
So, ich äh weiß, dass es äh.
Genau, also sag's mit Rainer Fassbinder, Angstessen, Seele auf ähm das müsst ihr irgendwie vermeiden.
Keine Angst, Freunde, keine Angst, wird alles super.
Gab's noch mehr Feedback.
Ja dann wichtiger Punkt ich hab in der letzten Sendung mehrmals gesagt die Betreiber oder Administratoren von Links unten in die Media wären verhaftet worden, dass es nicht der Fall die wurden nur wie man so schön sagt geratzt,
Also.
Man sowas.
Geratzt ist, wenn morgens um sechs die Tür aufgeht auf der falschen Seite der und.
Ist das auch Polizeichargon jetzt wieder, um das gleich mal zu klären oder ist das jetzt dann doch eher linker Lo.
Ich glaube, das ist eher lecker,
Also geratzt geht so, du nix im Bett, die Tür macht Wumps.
Und deine Computer sind weg. Und du kannst, wenn du zur Polizei gehst, sagen die nicht, oh okay, wir nehmen die Anzeige auf, sondern nee, den kriegen sie nicht zurück. So. Das ist geratzt. Ähm,
Ähm.
Okay, also die wurden geratzt.
Genau, die wurden geratzt äh und dann gab es eben diese ähm Verbotsverfügung auf den Verein,
Und dann gab es eben auch dieses autonome Zentrum in Freiburg,
dass bei dem dann da irgendwelche Objekte gefunden wurden,
Da gibt's auch einen Kommentar, der also solltet ihr nochmal die Kommentare dazu lesen, weil da äh Freiburger Leute auch nochmal mehr so für den über den Hintergrund der Szene in Freiburg und äh Kontroversen über äh links unten selber,
äh kommentiert haben, die glaube ich jetzt für das politische Gefüge ähm,
nicht besonders relevant sind, aber die interessant sind für Leute, die sich mehr für diese Seite und die Hintergründe in Freiburg und so interessieren. Gibt's da noch den ein oder anderen, sehr interessanten Kommentar.
Und dann wurde wurde noch eine Korrektur geübt, Briefwahl
offenbar bis zum zweiundzwanzigsten September achtzehn Uhr beantragen, das wäre Freitag,
nachgewiesener plötzlicher Erkrankung sogar noch bis zum Wahltag fünfzehn Uhr
der das Problem, was man hat, ist aber der,
die Briefwahl muss bis achtzehn Uhr am Wahltag vollzogen sein. Das heißt, wenn ihr jetzt wirklich noch Friedball beantragen wollt,
Heute Nachmittag zum Beispiel, dann solltet ihr am besten dorthin gehen, das beantragen und den Umschlag dann auch direkt wieder dort abgeben,
Also da gibt's nichts irgendwie mit, es gilt das Datum des Poststempels, nein, das muss um achtzehn Uhr am Wahltag da liegen. Also kann beantragt werden, solange wie man will. Man muss halt nur zusehen, dass man es auch noch dort unterbringt.
So, bevor wir jetzt aber auf unsere eigentliche Themenliste äh kommen, begrüßen wir noch einen Gast, den wir auch schon mal äh an Bord hatten, zweimal, glaube ich, sogar schon, nicht wahr? Äh wir begrüßen Kira, hallo, guten Tag.
Guten Morgen Deloves, guten Morgen Tim.
Ja und der Unterton äh verrät euch schon, heute geht's mal wieder ein bisschen um die Schweiz. Äh.
Sehr gerne.
Genau, äh wann hatten wir dich dabei? Wir hatten dich glaube ich letztes Jahr und dann auch zwanzig vierzehn schon mal äh glaube ich dabei, richtig?
Ja, das kommt hin.
Sendung können wir gleich nochmal raussuchen,
Genau und wir wollten uns mal so ein bisschen äh ein Update,
lassen wie bei euch so die netzpolitischen Bemühungen so vorangehen,
Aber vorher müssen wir, glaube ich, dann doch nochmal äh,
nochmal nach Deutschland zurückblättern, weil es gab ja so viel Broha wegen des ganzen äh PC Wahl, äh Hacks, den wir ja hier ausführlich dargelegt hatten in der vorletzten Sendung und auch letzte Mal nochmal.
Was ist denn da noch passiert.
Also es war ja,
im Prinzip dieser Bericht war da und es es lag jetzt am Hersteller sich um äh darum zu bemühen diese von uns gemeldeten Sprachstellen zu korrigieren,
Wir hatten ja äh den Hersteller auch schon vorher,
quasi über Zeit online informiert. Also wir waren ja der der Hersteller befand sich laut,
laut unabhängigen Köln seit Juli auch im Austausch mit den BSI.
Ähm immer wenn wir etwas gefunden haben, wurde das dem Hersteller zeitnah mitgeteilt. Ähm,
Und der Herr Scheller hat dann ja verschiedene Versuche auch unternommen, die Probleme in den Griff zu bekommen. Insbesondere das Problem der nicht signierten Updates,
In einem ersten Anlauf hat er dann dem Update eine MD fünf Summe beigelegt, was.
Die dann in dem gleichen Zip-Archiv lag, also kein wirksam Schutz geboten hat. Das war,
ein schöner schöne Idee, aber das bringt nichts, wenn du diese MD fünf Summe,
der gleichen Quelle bekommst, ne? Also eine MD fünf Summe kann jeder herstellen ähm.
Der ist ungefähr so, als ob du so ein Buch liest, wo ein Aufkleber draufsteht. Dieses Buch ist wahr.
Also es bringt halt, genau, es bringt nichts, ne? Du hast kein, es bietet dir keine Überprüfbarkeit. Ähm in einem zweiten Versuch hat er ja dann ähm die Software,
selber signiert, ähm nicht jedoch die Updates, sodass du auch bei signierter Software immer noch unsignierte Updates einpflegen konntest,
Auch da das haben wir dann auch in unserem, das war der Versuch vom fünften September und weil wir unseren Bericht am siebten September veröffentlicht haben, haben wir das auch da drin berichtet, dass diese diese Maßnahme nicht wirksam ist. Wir haben gesagt, bitte,
Implemier, implementiere doch ein Verfahren, wo du die Signatur der Updates prüfst,
Bevor du sie installierst, ganz einfach, wie das eigentlich alle machen, also das ist eine Funktion, die es gibt immer mal wieder Fälle, wo Software das nicht tut,
Aber in der Regel, also sowas wie, was weiß ich. Nur Windows Update oder so ein so ein App Store von Apple. Oder wenn du hier eine App auf deinem Telefon installierst, egal ob das jetzt ein Inrad ist oder so, dann wird geguckt, ob die, ob die Software signiert ist. Und zwar,
macht man da etwas, was sich ähm,
Also die Software, der Update weiß vorher, von welchen Instanzen er Updates akzeptiert, von wem die also signiert sein müssen.
Es reicht also nicht, dass sie signiert sind, sondern äh wenn du das nach Best Practice machst, weist der Update vorher,
Von wem die Sache, von wem das Update erwartet wird, prüft, ob es auch mit genau diesem Zertifikat signiert ist und führt es dann aus,
Am dreizehnten September kam also ein neues Update,
von PC Wahl und da wurde der Updater.
Aktualisiert und es war jetzt die Rede davon, der Update würde nun digitale Signaturen prüfen. Dann haben wir uns natürlich sehr viel interessiert. Thorsten Schröder hat sich das sofort angeschaut und ähm,
twitterte noch am gleichen Abend sehr ärgerlich, weil es elf Minuten nach Mitternacht war, sonst wäre es auch tatsächlich noch das gleiche Datum gewesen, sowas wie
und dann eine eine Schasume. Womit schon klar war, äh okay äh das Ding ist wieder Mist,
Und jetzt wird's wirklich also es ist inzwischen einfach nur noch absurd, was da passiert. In diesem Fall funktionierte der Installa folgendermaßen. In Stollar ähm,
lädt etwas runter, leg dir eine Datei auf die Festplatte, die die Endung EX Unterstrich hat,
Und das ist eine eigentlich nur ein Helloworld Programm, das signiert ist. Dieses Hello World Programm ist signiert.
Wird aber nicht ausgeführt, denn jetzt geht er in Storla hin, äh jetzt fordert der Installa dich auf als Nutzer, dass du die Signatur dieses Programmes, was da liegt, prüfst,
und zwar manuell. Ne? Und dann irgendwie so klicken sie mit der rechten Maustaste, klicken sie hier, klicken sie da, gucken sie sich das an. Bis da steht diese Signatur ist gültig.
Ja?
Ähm da steht aber nicht, bis da steht bist du halt wirklich der äh überprüft wird, von wem die Signatur ist,
Mit anderen Worten, es ist völlig egal, wer das Ding signiert, sie muss nur gültig sein. Und so ein Codesigning-Zertifikat kriegst du halt für einen Hoodie,
das wissen die auch, denn ihr es ist so ein einhundert Euro Zertifikat oder hundertfünfzig Dollar Zertifikat von,
Kumode oder Go Daddy oder irgendwie sowas, ne? Ähm.
Noch dazu haben sie den Firmennamen in diesem Zertifikat echt irgendwie so geschrieben, dass du schon denkst, das ist doch das ist doch ein falsches Zertifikat. Aber der entscheidende Punkt ist in diesem Verfahren
der Nutzer, erstens muss der Nutzer das Zertifikat prüfen, völliger Unsinn ist, warum sollte der Nutzer das Zertifik,
kannst du automatisch machen. Zweitens, wird der Nutzer nur bis zu dem Schritt angeleitet
dass da das Windows sagt hier ja es signiert ist gültig. Nicht aber zu dem Schritt zu sagen guck dir den Fingerprint von den Zertifikat an und prüfe ob das der Richtige ist,
Und wenn der, dann muss der Nutzer sagen, ja, habe ich gemacht, ist gültig, dann geht der ins Dollar hin und holt aus dieser signierten Datei,
Springt er in die richtige Stelle, holt sich das alte PC-Wahl-Update-Paketformat daraus. Also geht,
dieser signierten Datei geht der ins Dollar hin. Liest da einen Stream Teil raus,
Und für das führt das dann dem Alten in Storlar wieder zu, wo dann diese etwas krude Kryptographie zum Einsatz kommt und das Paket dann. Es ist wirklich also,
Es war Reha sehr einfach, dass eben Binnen weniger Stunden technisch nachzuvollziehen, was da geschieht. Aber die Beweggründe für ein solches Vorgehen haben wir bis heute nicht verstanden, weil es, es ist einfach unsinnig, ja, also was man machen würde, wäre.
Lade die Datei runter, guck, ob die mit dem Zertifikat signiert ist, dass du möchtest, pack sie aus. Von mir aus, mach sogar noch deine komische Gehirnschmalzgruppe Krypto drumherum, wende dich dann besser fühlst,
hilft nicht, schadet nicht, aber ähm wenigstens hast du diese Signaturprüfung automatisiert da drin, ja? Ähm.
Also man hat wirklich den Eindruck, dass sie eigentlich mit diesen ganzen Techniken überhaupt nicht vertraut sind.
Nein, also es wird fundamental, wirklich nicht verstanden, warum man signiert und fundamental nicht verstanden, wie man eine Signatur prüft,
nämlich anhand des Fingerprints des Kies, mit dem sie signiert wurde.
Sogar noch weitergehen. Also hier ist noch mehr, von daher hier ist sozusagen fundamental nicht verstanden worden, dass dass dieser gesamte Prozess sozusagen ein,
Ein Sicherheitsdenken folgen muss, was sozusagen von vom Anfang bis zum Ende durchdacht ist oder
anders formuliert. Man muss halt zu jedem Zeitpunkt irgendwie immer irgendwas äh immer alles sicherstellen sozusagen und bei jedem Schritt immer wieder schauen, was,
Was kann jetzt hier äh schiefgehen, wenn ich jetzt diese Maßnahme mache, kann das irgendwie dazu führen, dass ich hier äh ein reingewirkt bekomme,
Und das ist schon nicht so einfach, aber wenn man halt sozusagen diesen ganzen Prozess nicht verstanden hat oder beziehungsweise nicht gewohnt ist, in Prozessen zu denken,
sondern immer nur so in so einzelnen Schritten und einzelnen Maßnahmen,
wundere ich mich auch ehrlich gesagt da über nix mehr.
Vor allem also es ist einfach nicht. Es ist wirklich nicht nachvollziehbar, wie jemand zweitausendsiebzehn die Bürde der Zertifikatsprüfung,
auf den Nutzer abwälzen kann und wenn er es schon tut, das auch noch falsch zu tun. Ja, also es ist wirklich es ist nicht mehr nachzuvollziehen. Und wir waren auch ein bisschen ähm,
Ja wir waren wirklich fassungslos, weil wir nicht mehr, also weil ja, weil wir nicht wussten, was wir jetzt machen sollen, ja? Und dann haben wir einen Tag drüber nachgedacht,
Und dann haben wir gesagt, komm ähm,
Wir machen das jetzt einfach einmal richtig und schenken denen das. Und dann hat Thorsten sich hingesetzt und hat relativ einfach, ja? Ähm mit RSA-Signatur,
Beispielcode geschrieben, wenige Zeilen,
Für Windows mit kannst du mit dem aktuellen Visual Studio komplieren, einmal frei Haus und dann haben wir das veröffentlicht am ich glaube am Dienstag,
den zwölften nee den neunzehnten erfolgte dann die Veröffentlichung wo wir gesagt haben OK der Herrscher hat's jetzt dreimal versucht er kriegt's nicht hin
Es sind nur noch fünf Tage bis zur Wahl. Wir spenden die Lösung des Problems in Open Source, weil das ist ja das Wichtige für Wallsoffe, dass die Open Sources auf Gitarb und äh machen das quasi als
Geschenk.
Welcher Lizenz.
Lesser GPL
Also quasi Open Source und er darf es sogar verwenden und man verändern, ohne dass er es wieder äh quelloffen machen muss. Also wirklich, wir waren da,
äußerst äußerst verständnisvoll, ja? Und haben auch sogar ihm erlaubt, also haben sie es so gebaut, dass er seinen alten komischen Kryptogramm da auch noch weitermachen soll. Das Einzige ist, dass wir eben wollen, dass er RSA,
er signiert seine Update-Mass, wir haben ja auch gar keine großartigen äh Zertifikate verwendet, sondern es wird einfach einmal RSA signiert, du hast den Key, dein Updateprüfer, prüft das, alles fertig, ready to ship haben wir äh der Firma geschenkt
und äh gesagt, komm,
jetzt aber, ne? Jetzt kommt letzten paar Meter. Wir kriegen das noch hin vor der Bundestagswahl. Eine einmaliger Prozess, dass der CT1 Coach, spende mal. Wir haben's denn äh digitale Erste-Hilfe genannt.
Und nun ähm die jetzt war natürlich die Frage.
Natürlich geht das auch, glaube ich, mit einer gewissen ähm,
Da muss man über seinen Stolz hinweg springen, um dann diese diese Spende auch anzunehmen als Programmierer. Aber wenn man's eben dreimal nicht richtig hingekriegt hat, dann ist eben der Moment, in dem man sich von anderen helfen lassen sollte. Der wäre eigentlich schon sehr viel früher gewesen,
Ähm na ja, der Hersteller hat sich entschieden.
Diese Spende offenbar nicht anzunehmen. Und stattdessen keine Updates mehr über die Herstellerwebseite anzubieten.
Ja, sondern.
Ähm der stand jetzt dann der der Text sowas wie ich habe, musst du mal ganz kurz schauen,
das stand jetzt, wenn du auf die Update-Seite gegangen bist und auch wenn du in PC Wahl jetzt ein Update machen wolltest.
Ähm kriegtest du die Meldung.
Das aktuelle Update ist für PC Wahlanwender nur noch per Individualbezug oder über die zuständigen Servicedienstleister erhältlich. Bitte nehmen sie hierzu mit ihrem Betreuer Kontakt auf. So.
Das heißt, das heißt, in der freien, jeder PC-Wahlanwender sitzt am neunzehnten September,
da mit einer verwundbaren Version von PC Wahl. Neunzehnter September ist der Dienstag,
Am Sonntag ist Bundestagswahl und es gibt nun keine,
automatischen Updates mehr, wer und alle, die da draußen sind, sind verwundbar. Und der Hersteller weigert sich, denen noch Updates zu geben. Es sei denn, sie melden sich bei dem, warum tut der Hersteller das.
Damit du dich nochmal bloß gestellt wird. Ja.
Damit wir nicht nochmal draufgucken können. Das heißt, was der, was da jetzt passiert ist, die Software wird aus der kritischen Auge der Öffentlichkeit gezogen, damit wir nicht nochmal drauf schauen und weitere.
Ähm weitere Fälle von Gehirnschmalz finden.
Flüchtete er sich in die Intransparenz, in genau das eine Problem, was diese Software hat, wird jetzt weiter ausgeführt,
er lässt noch dazu nicht mal eine Woche vor der Bundestagswahl.
Seine kompletten Anwender im Regen stehen. Das ist das unverantwortungsloses, äh das Verantwortungsloseste, was ich,
Ich hätte mir das nicht vorstellen können, dass das so agiert worden würde. Ich bin fassungslos. Ich bin wirklich ich konnte den Abend nicht schlafen, weil ich so.
Also weil ich das so krass finde, ja wir vertrauen dieser Firma und diesem Entwickler mit unserer Bundestagswahl.
Und der lässt eine weniger als eine Woche vorher uns alle im Regen stehen,
Und wenn er jetzt behauptet, er würde die Softwareupdates ausgerollt bekommen. Bin weniger Stunden, ja, über diese verschiedenen Vertriebskanäle und Wartungsprozesse, die er hat. Das ist einfach nicht wahr, denn wir wissen,
von unseren Quellen, die wir haben, dass diese Updates dann noch nicht angekommen sind. Noch dazu, wenn man also heute auf die Seite geht, wird da eine äh,
Eine äh sehr krude Angabe gemacht. Das ist wirklich ähm also ich bin.
Also ich meine über den Laden sich jetzt noch groß aufzuregen müsst, äh fällt mir ehrlich gesagt schwer, weil das da habe ich keine Erwartung, ne.
Nein, nein, das ist, deswegen haben wir es ihnen ja gespendet.
Ja nee, ist ja auch alles ein super Move, nur äh wer hier jetzt eigentlich am Zug ist, sind halt einerseits äh DSI,
denn Sonntagsreden ja nun auch schon seit äh Jahren, halben Jahr. Wir haben noch hier diese Vereinbarung, diese Vereinbarung und,
alles vorgeschrieben und das ist ja alles Standard und sing Naturgesetz und hast nicht gesehen
Nur erhält sich halt offensichtlich noch nicht mal jemand dran, der irgendwie so an den
der Reihen des kritischsten äh eines der kritischen Vorgänge dieser Bundesrepublik seine Hand dran hat,
Womit natürlich auch dieses ganze,
System der Empfehlungen durch das BSI einfach weiterhin zu zu kritisieren ist. Das funktioniert alles nicht,
muss alles anders aufgesetzt werden.
Also dieses dieses Ding irgendwie man könnte das vergleichen mit der Kapitän der Titanic fährt nicht nur einmal vor den Eisberg, sondern dreimal.
Und verpisst sich dann und lässt die anderen zurück. Das ist das, was hier geschehen ist. Er weigert sich jetzt, diesen automatisierten Prozess weiter äh zu verwenden. Und die Leute, die die Software jetzt noch haben,
Sitzen da und kriegen noch nicht mal mehr ein Update. Was er tun müsste ist.
Wenn er sagt, okay, ich möchte auf dieses automatische Update verzichten. Kann er ja machen, dann muss er das erst in der Software ausbauen. Und dann kann er sagen, es gibt keine Updates mehr. Aber letztendlich müsste er auf der, muss er auf seinem Server,
Das Update liegen haben, was diese, was beim nächsten Update, den Update löscht.
Das wäre die Möglichkeit gewesen zu sagen, okay,
Ich sehe, ich verstehe, ich schaffe es nicht, ein Update, am einen Update-Prozess zu bauen. Ich bin zu stolz,
Spende vom CC anzunehmen, was ich verstehen kann. Das war ja auch ein bisschen giftiger Apfel.
Ja oder technisch nicht in der Lage.
Technisch nicht in der Lage geht nicht, weil da wir haben wirklich feine Anleitungen dazu. Ich glaube, da liegt sogar das kompeierte Paket drin, weiß ich nicht genau, habe ich nicht. Also das aber okay, vielleicht auch nicht dazu in der Lage.
Aber diese diese Verantwortungslosigkeit, mit der die Leute, die ihnen anvertraute Aufgabe.
Betrachten, ja? Und sagen, ne, dann nicht. Nee, wenn ihr mir jetzt zum dritten Mal das kaputt macht, dann dann gibt's eben keine Updates mehr, dann könnt ihr zusehen, wer mit eurer Bundestagswahl klarkommt. Das ist wirklich, wirklich nur noch schockierend. Wirklich bin schockiert. Ähm.
Ja und jetzt keine Ahnung, fünf Tage vor der Wahl sitzen wir also da mit einer kaputten Software. Vielen Dank.
Ja, ich sehe das Problem höher angelegt, ne? Also ich meine,
Das ist jetzt eine Bude und ich glaube, wir können uns noch beliebig viele andere äh Buden, die in diesem ganzen Prozess unterwegs sind, vornehmen. Äh bisher ist ja alles zu Staub zerfallen, was man sich mal irgendwie äh in diesem ganzen Wahlprozess. Ich meine, äh,
gab's schon mal irgendwann mal den Fall, dass man sich mal was angeschaut hat und festgestellt hat, so oh, aber da hat ja mal wirklich einer drüber nachgedacht,
Nee, sondern alles, was bisher auch nur ansatzweise mal angeguckt wurde, äh kippt einfach sofort aus dem Latschen und wir sind verängstigt da äh Teenager auf einer Heavy Metal Party. Das ist,
einfach,
Das ist einfach das ist einfach der die ja? Da wird einfach mit nicht aktueller und nicht mit Software und nicht mit aktuellen Softwaremethoden und mit einem,
vollkommen veralteten beziehungsweise nicht vorhandenen Sicherheits äh und komplex,
Verständnis äh,
wenn da Systeme gebaut, so nach dem Motto, ja, passt schon irgendwie.
Also ich vermute, was passieren wird, ne? Ähm das BSI wird eine relativ bald dann eine technische Richtlinie, weil,
Software formulieren
und ähm dann werden die sich in den nächsten Legislaturperiode bemühen, diese in ein Gesetz zu gießen, ne? Änderungen des Wahlgesetzes, jede Softwarekomponente, die an der Auswertung oder sowas beteiligt ist muss,
BSI Zertifikat. Haste nicht gesehen oder nachrichtliche Richtlinie so und so sein
dann kann man hoffen, dass diese Richtlinie sinnvoll ist und dann kann da vielleicht nochmal was draus werden. Das vermute ich, ist das, was die gerade ähm was, wie diese Nummer noch mein Ende finden wird. Ähm gleichzeitig gehe ich auch davon aus, dass diese
Software am Ende nicht mehr zum Einsatz kommen wird, denn sie wurde ja von dem,
jetzigen Eigner gekauft, um äh wurden ja im Prinzip die Kunden gekauft und nicht die die Software. Na ja.
Aber wirklich toll, wirklich toll wie wie hier vorgegangen wird.
Wir sind gespannt, wie die andere Software, die sie im Angebot haben, sich so äh machen wird, wenn man sie sich mal genauer anschaut.
Wie sieht's denn aus mit in der Schweiz? Ist bei euch denn wenigstens noch alles in Ordnung, Kira?
Es sucht hier auch etwas,
Überblick verloren zu gehen, was was Netzpolitik alles so läuft, es ist ziemlich viel los.
Aber habt ihr den? Habt ihr denn auch so mit äh mit mit Wahl äh Systemen, was was ist denn da der Stand der Dinge.
Ja, es soll ähm die Wahlen online ähm stattfinden.
Oh
Stichwort Evoting. Ähm das ist Groß auf der Agenda. Das ist schon seit vielen Jahren latent ein Thema und soll jetzt zum Durchbruch verholfen werden im nächsten Jahr.
Da haben wir noch ein paar alte CC-Gutachten, die wir.
Im Schra.
Ja auch gerne zurück. Das ist schon so. Aber es ist äh auch da ist ein schwieriger Kampf.
Willkommen in den Wahlcomputer zum Einsatz.
Nein, das ist äh das ist nicht äh Wahlcomputer im äh im Wahllokal, im Stimmlokal, sondern das ist komplett online.
Nee, ist schon klar, aber kommen derzeit den äh Wahlcomputer zum Einsatz.
Nein.
Weil sie nicht dürften oder weil sie es nicht gemacht wird.
Weil es nicht gemacht wird.
Also es es gibt es gibt ähm unterstützende Geräte, um Stimmzettel auszuwerten. Aber sonst keine Wahlcomputer.
Um sie auszuwerten, okay, also abgestimmt wird äh quasi immer noch mit Bleistift, aber äh mit Kugelschreiber und äh aber es gibt dann Zählsysteme, also so optische Zählsysteme.
Genau, ja. Aber das ist halt, das ist sehr individuell. Wir wir haben das nicht zentralisiert, sondern das ist dann kein Kantonen und dann Gemeinden überlassen, wie sie das, wie sie das machen im Rahmen ihrer ihrer Lokalgesetze.
Also,
Das wäre auch nochmal interessant äh äh da mal hinterherzugehen, weil meine in dieser ganzen Diskussion um die Wahlcomputer äh kamen ja auch solche Sachen zum Einsatz, ne? Also es war ja immer die Argumentation geht ja immer so,
wählen ist ja mal voll anstrengend und da muss man ja irgendwie zwei Stunden lang Kreuze auf Zetteln, auf verschiedene Stapel verteilen und äh,
Das ist ja, das ist ja ein modern äh Bürger nicht mehr zuzumuten.
Und deswegen brauchen wir ja da unbedingt Hilfssysteme und deswegen gab's da verschiedene Ansätze und der eine Ansatz
Ist ja der, na ja, man stellt dann gleich mal einen Computer in die Kabine und wenn man auf die richtige Taste drückt, dann wird schon irgendwie das Richtige passieren und dann braucht man nur noch das Ergebnis ausdrücken und alle sind glücklich,
Dagegen sind wir ja äh ganz bewusst vorgegangen, haben gesagt, Leute, wenn ihr da eine Taste drückt, dann wisst ihr halt nicht, was da in dem Computer gezählt wird und da könnt ihr uns auch tausendmal irgendwie mit Open Source kommen und so weiter. Am Ende weiß niemand, was in diesem System,
Tatsächlich installiert ist, welcher Chip da äh die Hoheit hat, et cetera. Damit ist das Ganze ja auch gefallen,
In der ganzen Debatte kamen natürlich dann auch andere Vorschläge vor, wie zum Beispiel eben solche Zählsysteme, ja so nach dem Motto, dann machen wir es doch auf Papier. Dann haben wir da irgendwie einen Computer, der zählt dann sozusagen die Striche, wo aber dann das Argument sein muss. Na ja.
Wie überprüfst du das, dass irgendwie auch stimmt, was da gezählt wurde? So ja, von Hand zählen, ne? Aber wenn du sowieso von Hand zählen musst, wozu dann noch diesen Computer. Wenn du von Hand nicht mehr erzählst, überlässt es wieder im Computer und dann bist du schon wieder bei bei Position eins.
Also wenn das sozusagen tatsächlich zum Einsatz kommt, dann würde ich mir ja jetzt schon mal äh fragen,
ob's da überhaupt mit äh rechten Dingen zu sich geht. Und E-Voting, ich meine, also wer also Online-Voting, wer das äh ernsthaft fordert in diesen Zeiten,
hat sie ja wohl nicht alle. Also das kann man jetzt nicht anders, äh weil dann braucht man jetzt nur
sich mal den aktuellen Sicherheitsmarkt anschauen, ja, wie viele äh der PCs heutzutage mit Mywear äh attackiert werden et cetera, Lage, Skale
geohnt werden. Wenn man dann so ein Target hat, ja, wo man quasi nur durch irgend so eine blöde Infektionssoftware
Voting Programme et cetera Browser-Eingaben et cetera also.
Das das kann niemand ernsthaft wollen sich so ein Scheiß anzutun, weil dann ist halt einfach die Integrität der Wahl überhaupt nicht mehr sicherzustellen. Von dem Backend mal ganz abgesehen
was sozusagen dann äh zählt, weil es sei alles digital, der ganze Flow müsste abgesichert werden und es ist halt einfach äh schwer möglich.
Ja, es es wird davon ausgegangen, dass man ein System bauen kann, dass es zulässt, dass man seine Stimme komplett nachvollziehen kann. Also das, dass ich zum Schluss noch massiver Prüfung kann, o.
Meine Stimme auch tatsächlich so ins Resulta,
eingeflossen ist, wie ich das, wie ich sie abgegeben habe,
und lässt außer Acht, dass das vielleicht sogar technisch möglich ist, aber dass das niemand versteht,
dann dadurch die Transparenz der Wahlen verloren geht.
Beziehungsweise ja und da dadurch wird natürlich auch eine Stimme verkaufbar, ne?
Ja
Weil wenn ich, wenn ich einen dritten gegenüber äh äh überprüfen kann, hier guck mal, ich habe auch wirklich äh da eine bekloppte Partei gewählt jetzt mal her mit den zehn Euro. Ähm ne. Dann dann hat man.
Das sind dann auch die zusätzlichen Aspekte, die da alles noch hereinspielen, das ist genauso. Also das ist, das ist eine Quartatur des Kreises, die die funktioniert einfach nicht.
Ja, also man man kann gerne, wenn man, äh, wenn man sozusagen auf einen der Parameter einer freien Geheimgleichen
verzichten möchte, so dann kann man das mit Computern machen, aber man kann halt nicht Computer in dieses System einbringen und all diese ganzen Eigenschaften aufrechterhalten und das ist so ein
Problem, was offenbar noch öfter erläutert werden muss. Aber da haben wir ja,
eine ganz gute Basis, also wenn solche Pläne jetzt tatsächlich existieren, dann würde ich sagen, macht das mal, da kann man wunderbar argumentieren.
So, aber wir haben ja eigentlich ganz andere äh Themen in der Schweiz, die gerade am Kochen sind.
Ja, es ist schon so.
Mit schönen Namen, nämlich Kabel und Funkaufklärung. Kannst du uns zwar mal drüber aufklären.
Ja. Ähm wir haben ja im letzten Jahr, dass die Referendumsabstimmung,
gegen das Nachrichtendienstgesetz verloren. Das war ja im letzten Jahr ein großes Thema bei uns und in diesem Nachrichtendienstgesetz, dass
umfangreiche neue Befugnisse für den Geheimdienst schafft, ist unter anderem auch die die Kabelaufklärung,
ein Teil davon,
Und da geht es darum, dass man in Ergänzung zur bereits vorhandenen Funkaufklärung, wo es um Satellitenkommunikation geht, auch die Glasfaserkabel nach.
Definierten Zustichworte durchsuchen kann. Und das ist,
das Gesetz mit diesen neuen Befugnissen und der Kabelaufklärung ist jetzt per ersten September in Kraft getreten,
Und gegen diese Bestimmungen, welche die Kabel und die Funkhafklärung betreffen,
haben wir jetzt auch auf den ersten September eine Beschwerde erholen.
Was auf welcher Ebene, was heißt Beschwerde, also ist das jetzt so eine formale Beschwerde bei einer Behörde oder ist das jetzt gleich der Gerichtsweg.
Es es ist jetzt in der ersten, in der ersten Phase ist es ein Gesuch, das sich an den Nachrichtendienst, also an der an den Geheimdienst richtet
Als die Jahreskanzlei ist etwas anders bei uns als in Deutschland, weil wir kein Verfassungsgericht haben,
Das heißt, man muss aus einer persönlichen Betroffenheit ähm einen Antrag bei einer Behörde stellen. Also es ist es geht um Verwaltungsrecht.
Also wir gehen, wir sind acht Beschwerde für ihn und beschwerte für ähm zum Nachrichtendienst und sagen ähm,
dass die die Kabel und die Fondkraftklärung zu unterlassen sei. Und aus diesem, aus diesem Gesuch,
dass wir da dass wir dann,
Das ergibt eine Verfügung der Behörde, die sagt dann, wir geben dem Stadt oder was ziemlich sicher sein wird, wir geben dem Nichtstadt, wir geben euch nicht Recht. Und und auf diese Verfügung,
die kann man dann auf diese kann man eine Beschwerde führen und dann kommt der normale Gericht Gerichtsinstanzenweg,
dann zum Zug, die also die nach dem nach dem Nachrichtendienstgesetz, nach diesem Gesuch wird die nächste Instanz das Bundesverwaltungsgericht sein,
das Bundesgericht und und das letzten Instanz würde dann das europäische, der europäische Gerichtshof für Menschenrechte in Straßburg auch,
noch entscheiden können. Das wäre dann das wäre der wenn's wenn's so lange dauert, dann ist das das Ende.
Ist das aber auch nicht gesichert, dass man immer auf die nächste Instanz kommt, oder?
Wie meinst du das.
Na ja, also es ist äh kann.
Hier arbeiten wir Recht bekommen, dann dann ist für uns okay. Aber das ist, da ist leider nichts, nicht davon aus.
Aber ich meine äh habt ihr immer die Möglichkeit, äh auf die nächste Instanz zu gehen oder äh kann es auch sein, dass ein Gericht sagt, das ist jetzt auch nicht weiter, das ist jetzt rechtskräftig und das ist jetzt auch nicht weiter eskalierbar.
Das dürfte nicht möglich sein in dieser in dieser Frage. Also natürlich in in gewissen Verfahren von
von äh von nicht so großer Bedeutung ist, das ist das durchaus so, dass man das nicht weiterziehen kann in diesem Falle, wo es um,
Verletzungen der Menschenrechte geht äh ist das nicht möglich. Also da der Instanzenweg wird uns offen stehen.
Das heißt, es sei eher eine Frage des Durchhaltevermögens und der Finanzierung.
Das ist genauso. Wir berechnen, dass uns das einige Jahre beschäftigen wird. Ähm ja, dass wir auch dann etwas Atem.
Du hast gesagt, Beschwerde zwölf Beschwerdeführerführerinnen, Individuen oder äh Organisationen.
Also es ist einerseits mal die digitale Gesellschaft Schweiz als Organisation,
und sieben Personen, das sind Journalistinnen und Journalisten,
ist der schweizer Anwalt von Edward Snowden und das ist unter anderem auch andere Meister, der ja auch schon öfters,
es war,
und gerade der Antreter bringt noch die internationale Komponente ins Spiel, weil weil wir verknüpfen die,
bescheuert. Also, wir wir müssen ja von der persönlichen Betroffenheit ausgehen und jetzt ist es ja so, dass die Kapellaufklärung erst jetzt ab dem ersten September möglich ist. Wir verknüpfen diese aber mit der bereits bestehenden.
Satelliten und und und Funkaufklärung, die es ja schon gibt und die Satelliten aufqueren, die zielt ja eher tatsächlich auch, das kann man auch eher so argumentieren auf den,
Ausland, auf die ausländische Kommunikation ab und
Darum haben wir auch Personen aus dem Ausland, die eigentlich keinen Bezug zur Schweiz haben, keinen näheren Bezug zur Schweiz haben, die die mit dieser Beschwerde führen, weil es
diesen Aspekt gibt, der der eigentlich die huetisch tatsächlich nur ausländische Kommunikation betrifft,
Und das ist auch bei der, bei der bei der Korpolüberwachung dann anders,
Da ist er tatsächlich dann, auch wenn sie auf dem Papier, auf ausländischen Verkehr abzielt, ist das ja gar nicht möglich, weil.
Der einig, ein Kommunikationsende muss ja immer in der Schweiz sein, wenn es ein Kabel ist, dass das über die Grenze geht.
Und daher kommt dann auch die Betroffenheit von von allen Personen, die in der Schweiz leben. Also es sind da wie die zwei Aspekte, die wir verknüpfen.
Mhm. Jut. Oder beziehungsweise nicht so jut.
War so ganz kitzerisch gesagt, was ist so deine Erwartung, wie so die Reaktion sein wird?
Ähm das wird jetzt ein paar Monate gehen, bis wir bis wir die Verfügung des Nachrichtendienstes bekommen
eine Abstriche der Verfügung und dann werden wir den Instanzenzug, den Instanzenzug angehen. Die Reaktionen in den Medien und in den Kommentaren, die waren sehr gut
sehr gutes Feedback gehabt von allen Seiten, also es hat da auch ziemlich viel ähm ja,
Kraft wiedergegeben, um um das dann auch äh über die nächste Zeit weiter zu verfolgen.
Ist das neu? Dass die Medien da so? Beginn.
Ich hatte mal so bisher immer den Eindruck, dass das Thema schlägt so in der äh Schweizer Öffentlichkeit nicht so richtig an.
Ja, das, das ist schon. Es ist auch der ganze Abstimmungskampf, ums Nachrichtendienstgesetz, es
Es sind sehr viele Elemente darin und dann dann schauten die Leute,
wie auch ab und sagen dann ja es geht doch um unsere Sicherheit und und gehen hier gar nicht so, dann,
etwas tiefer rein und und und versuchen die die Auswirkungen auch zu verstehen. Und jetzt haben
beschränkt. Wir lassen ja alle anderen Elemente eigentlich aus dem Gesetz außen vor,
und und gehen dieses,
dieser Überwachung an und unter argumentieren dann natürlich auch ganz spezifisch, wo wo hier die Probleme liegen und das, dass das wird dann auch etwas einfacher.
Ja, verstehe.
Und daher ist das jetzt auch besser aufgenommen worden. Aber jetzt dann mal schauen, wie's wie die Aktion sein werden, wenn wenn die Verfügung
da noch vom vom Nachrichtendienst kommt und und wie da die Argumentation sein wird, auch gerade in der Öffentlichkeit, jetzt weniger juristisch, sondern vor allem in der Öffentlichkeit. Und wie, wie,
das dann aufgenommen wird.
Und äh könnt ihr dann noch irgendwelche Unterstützung gebrauchen zu diesem Zeitpunkt?
Ja auf jeden Fall dass äh das Verfahren kostet äh mehrere zehntausend zehntausend Franken Euro.
Diese Beschwerde schon.
Nein, das ganze Verfahren.
Was ich abzeichne sozusagen, ja.
Genau, aber natürlich initial ist es auch schon ähm,
ziemlich teuer, weil viele der Arbeit, die muss, die muss jetzt geleistet werden, also wir haben Gesuch gemacht, das hat
Das umfasst zweiundfünfzig Seiten, das ist eigentlich das enthält schon die ganze Argumentation. Und entsprechend sind da natürlich auch ähm
Anwaltskosten, die anfallen und ja, wir sind komplett spendenfinanziert und entsprechend auf Unterstützung angewiesen.
Informationen sucht gerne auf der Homepage der digitalen Gesellschaft Schweiz.
Mhm. Packen wir mit in die Links. Linus, hast du noch irgendwelche Anmerkungen.
Ich freue mich, dass äh da gekämpft wird. Ja, also mal irgendjemanden
Das ist natürlich ein Thema, Kabelaufklärung, also es sind immer schwer äh auch vom zu vermittelnde Themen. Und wenn man da umso
wenn man es schafft da überhaupt positives Feedback
der Bevölkerung in Anführungszeichen zu kriegen, wenn man es schafft, sich da rein zu äh hängen, das ist äh eine harte, undankbare Arbeit und wie du gerade schon sagst, kostet viel Geld, wird wahrscheinlich über Jahre gehen
das ist schon sehr wichtig, dass sowas geschieht und da kann man,
gut mal paar Euro mit reinwerfen. Oder Franken.
Ja, sie, es ist auch zu hoffen, dass das natürlich auch internationale Auswirkungen hat oder Signalwirkung hat, insbesondere, wenn's dann von vom europäischen
Gerichtshof für Menschenrechte auch beurteilt werden muss, weil die Überwachungsmaßnahmen, die sind ja überall ungefähr dieselben.
Ja
Das Problem war ja hier auch in dem Moment, wo natürlich das EuGH da äh entsprechend urteilen würde, also optimalerweise natürlich in Favorit of Visites, äh wäre das natürlich dann auch in Deutschland wieder aufm Tisch.
Dann äh machen wir doch nochmal einen kurzen Ausflug auf über den Teich, aber äh nicht zu Rocketman und seinem,
Lieblingsfeind? Sondern zu Corry Doktor Row.
Von seinem Lieblingsfak.
Seinem Lieblingsfeind dem Digital Rights äh Management. Also worum geht's? Ähm ich bin mir gerade gar nicht so sicher, wir hat,
Wir hatten das mal, ne? Genau. Also es geht um die sogenannten Encrypted Media,
Extensions. Das ist eine Erweiterung der Webstandards durch das World Wide Web Konsortium, kurz W drei C.
Und Ziel der ganzen Geschichte ist, dass man quasi Digital Rights Methoden, DM.
Anwenden kann im Web. Hintergrund ist natürlich der,
Es gibt ein riesen Markt im Bereich Fernsehen, im Web, Filme, im Web, Videocontent, letztlich natürlich auch Audio, aber es geht natürlich hier vor allem erstmal um Video und einen entsprechend großen Markt.
Na ja und wie das eben so ist, in dem Moment, wo halt äh Videomaterial, unverschlüsselt im Netz angeboten wird, lässt es sich natürlich dann auch verhältnismäßig leicht äh kopieren und wieder äh,
wieder neue verbreiten. Das findet auch statt
Das hatten wir ja in den letzten Jahren auch verschiedenste Auseinandersetzungen mit so Sides, die ja
Filme happhaft geworden sind und die dann irgendwie selber angeboten haben, hier so Kino Punkt T O ähnliche Auseinandersetzungen, wobei man eigentlich immer auch seinen Eindruck hatte, die hatten am Ende auch gar kein Problem
sozusagen ihre Quellen
und ihre ihre Filmmaterialien dann auch äh äh selber äh zu finden. Aber es gibt natürlich grundsätzlich diese Angst, dass in dem Moment, wo jetzt äh keine Ahnung, irgend so eine populäre Fernsehserie
dann halt angefangen wird mit PayPalview angeboten zu werden, dass man dann eben relativ schnell sehen würde, dass hier auf allen möglichen,
allen möglichen Orten auch noch herauskommen.
Kurze Heimat, das ist relativ egal, ob man die verschlüsselt oder unverschlüsselt anbietet, ne. Also,
solange ich in der Lage bin, das bei mir wiederzugeben, bin ich ja auch in der Lage, das zu entschlüsseln, ne? Also, das ist jetzt nicht das
Das Kernproblem, ob's verschlüsselt ist oder nicht, aber man will es, versuchen, den Nutzern so schwierig wie möglich zu machen.
Genau. Genau, also und und vor allem sozusagen auch die Verschlüsselung, die Entschlüsselung so spät wie möglich erfolgen zu lassen.
Und das ist aber auch etwas, was seit jeher schief geht, ne? Man erinnert, es ist bei DVD schiefgegangen, es ist bei Blu-ray schiefgegangen und es äh es ist auch bei jedem bisher anderen Verfahren schiefgegangen.
Schiefgang im im Sinne von es sind Methoden gefunden worden, um das wiederum zu umgehen.
Ich darf da an das Kerkoff-Schir-Prinzip erinnern, dass wir sehr oft im Rahmen von PCWal hier nochmal berührt haben und erläutert haben. Was da zum Einsatz kommt, ist in der Regel symmetrische Kryptographie und wenn ich in der Lage bin,
zu Endschlüsseln bin ich auch in der Lage zu verschlüsseln, aber unabhängig davon, ob symmetrisch oder asymmetrisch ist.
Man liefert ja den Menschen das Bild. Er soll den Film ja gucken können,
Er wird den, er sieht den ja auch. Das heißt, die ultimat, der ultimative Weg ist am Ende dann von mir aus, dann nimmst du eben deinen Bildschirm wieder auf, ne? Machst du einen Bildschirmvideo oder sonstiges. Also wenn ich einem Menschen das Video geben möchte,
und er ist sich angucken soll, dann kann er muss er es ja entschlüsseln können, also kann ich auch nicht wirksam verhindern,
dass es in irgendeiner Form speichert. Man will es aber so schwer wie möglich machen.
Und ähm bisher werden aus diesem Grunde eben äh diese diese Flashgeschicht,
so benutzt, ne? Das ist ja auch jetzt nicht unbedingt das Schönste, damit schreiben sich die Leute da irgendwelche
ob's Kuren, Flash-Plugins und versuchen dadurch sich die Videos zu übertragen und es irgendwie zu erschweren, dass dem Nutzer nicht einfach
wie es in HTML fünf wäre im Prinzip ein Videotec mit einer mit einer MP vier Datei gegeben wird wo er dann einfach mit WG sich die MP vier Datei runterlegt. Ne, das das will man irgendwie
so schwer wie möglich machen.
Ja auch im Bereich Screenshoting, also äh Bildschirmaufzeichnung et cetera werden ja auch Hürden gesetzt, nicht wahr? Es gibt ja dann auch bei HDMI äh auch nochmal entsprechende Copyright Protection, also man versucht im Prinzip das, was schon lokal in den Geräten
vorhanden ist, also die eingebauten Bildschirme von Laptops oder eben auch digital angeschlossenen Bildschirmen, Beamern, et cetera
das will man dann sozusagen noch verlängern in den Browser selber
Damit eben auch der Browser mitspielen kann. Und jetzt muss man ja auch sagen, was ist denn die Argumentation vom W drei C das zu machen? Das ist halt so dieses, na ja, wenn wenn wir das nicht machen, dann,
dann bleiben wir halt einfach komplett außen vor.
Ja, das ist nicht so, dass sich dann auf einmal alle benötigt sehen, so ein äh freies äh äh Web zu unterstützen und alles wird irgendwie happy familymäßig, äh unverschlüsselt weitergegeben, sondern
das ganze verlagert sich halt in Apps, so wie wir sie eben derzeit haben. Und Apps
können dann wiederum tun und lassen was sie wollen. Das tun sie auch, Netflix et cetera, all diese ganzen Dienste, um die es hier äh äh letzten Endes geht
tun genau das und haben auf ihren Plattformen dann eben ihre eigenen Beine ries, da sind dann halt die entsprechenden Schlüssel,
äh versenkt oder die entsprechenden Methoden dieser Schlüssel zu übertragen, drin versenkt und äh von daher ist es die Argumentation des W drei C
Wollen wir, dass das Web quasi obsoliert wird, indem wir äh hier außen vor sind und wenn wir dann hier diesen Schritt mitgehen, dann dann bleiben wir halt, können wir halt auf der Party noch irgendwie
mit der Kohle in der Hand äh rumstehen.
Das ist eine ist durchaus ein Problem, ne? Also diese.
Nachvollziehbare Argumentation.
Und so. Also man kann sich schon vorstellen, dass dann so jemand wie Netflix in diesem W drei C sitzt und sagt Freunde.
Wir müssen das nie machen.
Wir müssen halt nicht machen. Müssen wir echt nicht. Du bist gar kein Problem. Dann machen wir hier unsere schöne Amazon App, unsere Playstation-App und die iPad App,
über Sweap kann man kann man die Kreditkartendaten angeben. Ist ja super, die Standards habt ihr dafür ja bereitgestellt gestellt, habt ihr fein gemacht, ja,
Also genau diese Sorge und äh es hat natürlich, man kann auch argumentieren, diese blöden Plugins will ja auch echt keiner haben.
Nee.
Also es gibt tatsächlich unschöne.
Aber es gibt oder sagen wir, schmerzhafte, aber es gibt Argumente.
Für dieses Encrypto Media Extensions zu machen.
Selbst wenn man, selbst wenn man gegen DAM ist. Das zeigt sich auch in dem ähm,
In der W drei C gezeigt. Jetzt wurde aber, das ist mein Verständnis und wir haben auch hier darüber berichtet, in der W drei C schon vor längerer Zeit entschieden, dass man dieses Encrypto Media Extensions machen würde. Es gab noch einen anderen wichtigen Argumentations,
Punkt dagegen, damit dieses Ding damit dieses Incript Media Extensions in irgendeiner Form wirksam ist, kann es nicht Open Source sein.
Es muss ähm,
Im Prinzip als Block ausgeliefert werden, also als binärer Club Klumpen, der mit reingepflanzt wird in den Browser, denn sonst,
hat man ja kein Geheimnis, ne? Also wir sehen hier PC Wal Edits Best, wir geben, ja, ist so. Wir geben dir deine, wir geben dir den Verschlüsselungsteil, wir versuchen den aber so gut wie möglich irgendwie dir zu entziehen, selbst wenn wir wissen.
Dass du ultimativ in der Lage bist, den zu brechen.
Und dann hat die Weder, dann hat die Wederer C das entschieden, das zu tun. Und zwar gegen Protest der Mitglieder und das ist äh wie Korridor schreibt ähm etwas Seltenes. In der Regel hat, ist die W drei C etwas ein ein Konsortium, das einstimmig.
Weil so gut wie. Wie einstimmig seine Standards,
entscheidet. Hier hat das Präsidium sich quasi darüber hinweg gesetzt, hat dieses.
EME Encypted Media ins Extensions entschieden. Und dann hat die IFF dagegen einen Repeel eingereicht und hat gesagt, nein, das wollen wir nicht. Äh oder wir akzeptieren, dass ihr das tut. Aber,
Es gibt eine es gibt ja den Digital Millennium Copyright Act. Der übrigens wie in Deutschland auch,
also ähnlich in Deutschland haben wir auch diese Gesetze. In Deutschland wird's ungefähr gesagt so, dass das umgehen,
einer wirksamen Maßnahme für Kopierschutz im Prinzip verboten wird.
Was ja schon in sich ein ein Widerspruch ist, denn wenn.
Sie wirksam ist, wie soll man sie dann umgehen können.
Genau, wenn sie wirksam ist, dann kann man sie nicht umgehen. Ähm aber das ist äh das ist in Deutschland, wie auch in den USA, ist im Prinzip das Umgehen von Kopierschutz nicht USO ist unter Strafe gestellt.
Wenn sie, wenn du über meinen Jägerzaun steigst, den ich aufgestellt habe, um die bösen Feinde rauszuhalten, dann ist das sozusagen verboten.
Da haben wir interessante, also da gab's dieses Anni DVD Gerichtsverfahren. Das ist übrigens auch der Grund, warum ihr
wenn ihr so 'n DVD-Ripper oder so was habt, ne? Dass ihr euch immer nochmal aus 'ner zweiten Quelle,
den äh Content, Shrramling, Dingens, das den Content-Srabbling-Brecher holen müsst, weil den nämlich keiner äh vertreiben darf.
Ähm also der Digital Millennium Copyright Act.
Ermöglicht in dem Moment, wo EMI in der Form äh verabschiedet sind, sind sie also ein wirksamer Schutz, dessen Umgehung prinzipiell nach dem DMCA,
unter Strafe steht. Und dann hat die IFF gesagt, okay Freunde, ihr wollt eure ähm.
Ihr wollt euer DAM haben? Wir finden das nicht gut, aber wir akzeptieren, dass ihr es jetzt macht,
Aber jetzt mach doch bitte eine Sache, ähm wir möchten, dass ihr,
Covernent macht und die Übersetzung von einem Covernente ist ein äh feierlicher Schwur. Wir wollten, dass es die Mitglieder des W drei C feierlich schwören, dass sie nur gegen jene vorgehen.
Die die äh IMI umgehen zum im Sinne des.
Des Verletztens von Copyright. Sagen, wenn jemand hingeht,
zum Beispiel aus Gründen der IMI Reverse in manipuliert. Oder für eine Sicherheitsforschung na um irgendwie,
die die Kryptografie voranzubringen. Schwachstellen zu finden. Ihr habt ja da auch.
Die Wirksamkeit zu überprüfen.
Die Wirksamkeit zu verbessern oder zu verschlechtern ähm oder zum Beispiel auch wenn du dein Bein Reblock lieferst, ne, dann äh
ich meine, der kann ja Schwachstellen enthalten. Jetzt muss es ja einem Forscher ähm ermöglicht sein, da drin Schwachstellen zu suchen. Dafür musste das Reverse enginieren. Dann wird der unter Umständen die Schwachstellen veröffentlichen.
Oder euch mitteilen und äh in den USA gibt es viele Fälle, wo Leute, die Sicherheitsforschung gemacht haben, am Ende,
Probleme mit dem DMCA unter DMCA bekommen haben und deswegen sagte sagte die IFF jetzt so wir schlagen vor,
dass ihr, dass alle Mitglieder des äh,
des DRM, äh des W drei C einen feierlichen,
Schwur leisten äh dass sie ähm.
Ihre rechtlichen Möglichkeiten in jede in jeglicher Direktion, die also die Umgehung von technischen äh Copyright äh DAM-Maßnahmen ermöglicht, ihre Wahrnehmung der Rechte beschränken auf,
Ähm,
Copyright und niemanden verfolgen, weil er äh irgendeine Art der Implementierung dieser Spezifikation umgeht, dass er äh,
nicht Compliance Veränderungen vornimmt, zum Beispiel für die äh Excessibility oder Schwachstellen da drin forscht, äh erforscht und veröffentlicht,
dass der, dass man das quasi sich alle Mitglieder der W dreizehn verpflichten, ihre rechtlichen Maßnahmen nur für die Verletzung ihrer Popyrides zu verwenden.
Was mir ein bisschen komisch vorkommt, weil.
Dass du jetzt irgendwie in der feierlichen, in der Feier, in der Gilde des W3C Konsortium einen feierlichen Schwur geleistet hast, äh wird dich im Zweifelsfall nicht daran hindern.
Covernent heißt auch einfach äh rechtlich gesehen, einfach eine urkundliche niedergelegte.
Feierlicher Schwur.
Vertragsfindung ja.
Aber ein Pakt mit dem mit dem Teufel. Ein Pack mit dem Gott, mit dem Engel, ein ein Takt mit Tim Burnerslee.
Wieder mit dir durch. Also.
Ähm hindert, ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das in irgendeiner Form rechtlich bindend ist. Aber es ist glaube ich eine eine gute Absichtserklärung.
Ich freue mich vor allem an wen genau sich das jetzt hier äh wendet, weil die Leute, die den Standard machen sind ja nicht am Ende diejenigen, die hier die Richterinhaber sind,
Also es hält sind ja nicht die Hollywoodstudios, die im W drei C äh Konsortium sitzen, aber das sind ja diejenigen.
Schon so ein bisschen. Also Netflix und so sitzen da.
Ja, aber Netflix ist nicht der Contentanbieter. Netflix ist nur
Nutzer äh davon und es wird auch dann nicht der einzige bleiben, weil in dem Moment, wo das halt da ist, äh wenn wir das natürlich auch sehen, dass auch andere das benutzen und es gibt ja auch noch äh diverse Kompetitoren, die es vielleicht noch gar nicht gibt
Ja, also ich meine, kann ja morgen eine neue Bude aufmachen, die dasselbe äh benutzt. Von daher ist mir diese ganze Argumentation derzeit noch so ein bisschen Schlaf, was die EFF hier
tatsächlich erwartet hat, was wie man das vielleicht wirklich noch zum besseren wenden kann, ne.
Äh also mir kommt das auch ein bisschen komisch vor. Hm, die IFF nennt aber viele Beispiele, ne? Also irgendwie wo.
Wo es Probleme gab mit dem US Copyright Office und in welche Sicherheitsbereiche das geht, also irgendwie Autos. Äh Softwaresecurity allgemein, ähm.
Der äh.
Wahlmaschinen haben sie hier genannt, ja. Medical Device, ja? Sagen so, jetzt ist doch alles in unserer eigenen Interesse, dass der DMCA,
hier nicht zur Anwendung kommt und Sicherheitsforschung und Verbesserung für uns alle existieren. Nun wurde darüber abgestimmt.
Und es gab die Entscheidung viel mit achtundfünfzig Prozent für diese EMI und ohne diesen diese Covern des IFF aus.
Tja, das ist eigentlich alles, das also man könnte jetzt sagen, die IFF wollte wirklich so das das Geringste, ne, einfach nur eine kommt. Lasst uns hier wenigstens eine eine gute Absichtserklärung mit hinzufügen. Selbst das wollten sie nicht.
Und jetzt hat äh die IFF sich ähm daraus verabschiedet.
Aus der W drei C. Haben gesagt, wenn das so ist, ihr habt alle Ideale verraten.
Spielen wir nicht mehr mit.
Jetzt spielen wir nicht mehr mit. Tja.
Ja Kira, weiß nicht, hast, hast, kannst du da irgendwie verstehst du das irgendwie, wie da die Zusammenhänge sind, wir stochern da so ein bisschen im Dunkeln.
Ja, es ist schon so, ich ich habe die Details auch nicht nicht so mitgekriegt, ähm aber es ist ja schon,
sehr wenig, was da nicht die IFF hier noch herauszuholen und versucht hat, also,
sehr, sehr weit über den Schatten mussten, die die Befürworter dieses Standards ja nicht springen,
wieso, dass das nicht geklappt hat.
Das ist dann wirklich, also das sehe ich,
an den Entscheid der EFF auch nachvollziehbar und zu sagen gut jetzt ist aber genug Freunde.
Bei uns natürlich die Frage, ob so eine rechtliche Konstruktion überhaupt gehalten hätte, ne. Also wie gesagt, man kann ja jetzt hier nur mit existierenden Unternehmen äh reden äh
Also eigentlich kann das ja nur auf Basis von Lizenzierung von Technologie funktionieren und das ist mir jetzt gar nicht so richtig klar
woher eigentlich jetzt dieser Algorithmen kommen, weil wenn's da jetzt einen Standard äh gibt, dann muss er da sozusagen eine Krypto umgesetzt werden. Und wenn man darauf jetzt irgendeine Limitierung äh äh legen kann, dann dann muss jetzt das sozusagen von denen, die da Patente spenden, et cetera äh kommen, dass man mit denen eine Vereinbarung macht, dass die dem nicht nachgehen.
Wie man das aber dann wiederum mit Copyrightverfolgung kombinieren kann, wo ja die Copyrights nun nicht unbedingt bei Anbietern von Kryptotechnologien liegen. Das das
mir alles noch ein bisschen schleierhaft.
Ja, das ist einfach so. Also, dass das Argument sein können,
dass es eben gar keine rechtliche Bindung ist, darum darum wollen wir diesen Kompromiss nicht. Aber auf der anderen Seite kann man auch sagen, weil es ja gar nicht so so stark festzumachen ist, kann man auch sagen, gut, wir akzeptieren das,
Wir machen das so. Wir schwören.
Ja, also es äh mal wieder so ein klassischer Beitrag bei Lok Bodennetzpolitik, wo wir dann mal ganz auf die Hörer äh setzen, mit vielleicht äh besserem Verständnis, entweder des konkreten Falls oder rechtlichen äh Situationen an der Stelle, wir geben zu da ein wenig zu ähm.
Also ich verstehe nur diesen rechtlichen Teil nicht, ne? Also warum äh erstens glaube ich nicht, dass dieser Covern in irgendeine sinnvolle rechtliche Bindung gefunden hätte und ähm,
Zweitens verstehe ich nicht, warum man ihn dann unbedingt ablehnen muss. Und was hier worüber die IFF sich aber insbesondere beschwert, ist,
dass sie quasi.
Überhaupt in so einer Abstimmungslage mit achtundfünfzig Prozent, das ist irgendwie das erste Mal, dass sowas passiert ist in der W drei C. Es ist auch das erste Mal, dass überhaupt in der WDR C jemand ein ähm Repeel vorschlagen musste,
und sie verstehen die klare Ablehnung ihres Covernens als eine
gegenteilige Absichtserklärung, also zu sagen, nein, wir werden auch auf die draufkloppen, die sich äh die sich unsere Sachen noch anschauen. Und damit eine eine doppelte,
Verletzungen der W drei C Prinzipien, ne? Offene Standards, Accessoire Twenny Body und dann noch irgendwie die Entscheidungsfindung ähm
Und da glaube ich regen die sich auch zu regen, die sich zurecht drüber auf und man muss eben auch überlegen, wie wer da eben Mitglied ist, ne? Irgendwie Netflix, Google, Apple, solche Unternehmen,
haben da natürlich wieder mal eine Möglichkeit genutzt.
Ihre Macht in diesen Ökosystemen zu zementieren.
Tja, ärgerlich.
Lass mal voranschreiten. Wir haben nochmal ein bisschen was äh aus der Schweiz. Und zwar.
Das ist daraus eigentlich geworden.
Ja, da haben wir auch schon darüber gesprochen vor vor längerer Zei.
Und das ist ja jetzt bei uns mittlerweile auch durch, das kommt jetzt,
oder das tritt jetzt ziemlich sicher am ersten Januar zweitausendundachtzehn in Kauf und dieses Überwachungsgesetz
beinhaltet ja ebenfalls Staatstrojaner im Ketchup, Tennensuchläufe, das sind äh Funkzellenabfahrten,
und ähm jetzt über Unterschied zum Nachrichtendienstgesetz, wo es den Geheimdienst betrifft, ist das ist das äh dieses Überwachungsgesetz für die Strafverfolgungsbehörden,
Und so wie es auch aussieht, also das Gesetz ist durch, jetzt geht's noch um die,
Details und da sieht's aus wie wenn der der gesetzliche Rahmen der gesteckt ist maximal,
ausgenutzt wird, das geht soweit, dass man,
Antennensuchläufer oder solche Funkzellenabfahre sogar bis ins äh WLAN,
haben möchte, also in in äh unter Umständen private ähm ähm Wifis.
Und ja, das wird uns jetzt noch etwas beschäftigen bis bis das dann ähm im Januar kommt.
Äh was heißt euch noch ein bisschen beschäftigen, wie wie werdet ihr euch damit.
Es hat jetzt diese noch 'ne Anhörung stattgefunden, also über diese über diese Ausführungsbestimmungen, wo wir uns auch nochmals
ähm äußern konnten und dann gibt es auch schlussendlich so wie auch ein paar rechtliche Einschätzungen, die man machen muss, wer jetzt dann wo,
In welcher Form unter dieses Gesetz fällt.
Um da auch noch, also wir haben auch sehr viele Anfragen aktuell vor von Leuten, die die jetzt unsicher sind, bin ich dann betroffen, muss ich überwachen, muss ich Daten speichern und da auch etwas äh
auch etwas Rechtssicherheit zu bekommen. Weil es ist ja, es ist ja nicht nur so, dass neue, das neue,
Dienste jetzt unter die Überwachung fallen, sondern dass auch neue Anbieter dazukommen,
Dass das vorhandene Gesetz, das hat vor allem auf die Access Provider abgezielt und neu sind,
eben dann auch Diensteanbieter oder oder
auch Anbieter, die jetzt nicht unbedingt den klassischen Internetzugang zur Verfügung stellen.
Und das sind so die die Fragen, die,
die aktuell im Arm stehen und natürlich auch zu hoffen, dass dass ähm das nicht maximal ausgenutzt wird, was was aktuell leider etwas danach aussieht.
Dass es irgendwie halt auch tatsächlich noch nach Möglichkeiten für freies und offenes WLAN gibt.
Was wir, was wir machen konnten, also das ist das war schon während dem äh während dem es noch im Parlament war, immerhin mal verhindern, dass die Vorortsdatenspeicherung nicht ausgedehnt wird. Mindestens zeitlich nicht,
da war's, das war geplant von von sechs auf zwölf Monaten zu gehen, dass das bleibt jetzt weiterhin bei sechs,
aber das ist natürlich auch nicht das, was wir wollen. Und in dem Abend haben wir ja auch noch ein Verfahren hängig
Also da, da läuft ja auch eine Beschwerde der digitalen Gesellschaft Schweiz. Und die ist allerdings schon ziemlich deutlich weiter, da stehen wir aktuell beim Bundesgericht.
Und da ist jetzt aktuell auch eine Anerhöhung ähm offen, wo wir uns noch was zum Verfahren äußern können. Also es hat jetzt Stellungsnahmen gegeben von von der das Whiskom,
Datenschutzbeauftragten, von der Überwachungsbehörde zu diesem, zu unserer Beschwerde und da können wir uns jetzt noch was äußern und dann geht es, dann kommt es dann zur zur Entscheidung,
die dürfte dann im Laufe des nächsten Jahres fallen.
Okay. Tim, du guckst.
Ja, ich meine, ich äh frage mich, ob da jetzt sozusagen äh ob noch irgendwas zu machen ist oder ob das jetzt alles erstmal auf einen zurollen muss.
Viele Spiele sollten jetzt einfach, ja, das ist schon so.
Was wir, was wir da noch haben, dass wir so dem der nächste Block ähm aus dem netzpolitischen Geschehen in der Schweiz, das sind Netzsperren.
Die zurück können uns ziemlich stark und auch sehr konkret mittlerweile. Wir haben drei Gesetzesvorlagen,
beinhalten,
und eines davon, das ist, das wird gerade jetzt in diesen Tagen in in Parlamen,
handelt, das geht jetzt von der einen Kammer in die andere Hin und hin und her, das ist das Geldspielgesetz,
weil ich es ähm ausländische Onlineglück spiele,
verbieten soll und dann auch äh dass das technisch durchgesetzt werden soll.
Durch was, also durch, also wird gesagt, auf welcher Art und Weise das technisch durchgesetzt werden soll oder wird das quasi den Providern überlassen?
Das das
Es wird umrissen, das sieht nach Dänesssperren aus, ist aber nicht dann im Gesetz nicht so konkret, dass das fixiert ist. Also das wird man dann auch anpassen können, je nachdem, wenn man merkt, dass das gar nicht funktioniert, weil zum Beispiel das Ganze eh mit
äh
mit mit Tierlass abgesichert ist oder der ins Spiel kommt, der Zettel mindestens untergräbt, damit man da da wird man dann allerfalls noch was darauf zurückkommen. Also es ist, also die,
Es ist die Sperr ist ja nur ein Teil, was sie machen möchten. Sie möchten auch eine Umleitung hin hinkriegen und das funktioniert halt nicht.
Also es soll, es soll eine Hinweisseite kommen, die den Benutzer sagt äh lieber lieber Online-Glückspieler, du, du wirst es jetzt ins böse Ausland,
und geh doch auf diese inländischen lizenzierten Casinoseiten und.
Genau diese diese Umleitung, die die ist technisch nicht machbar,
Wir haben versucht, das irgendwie Parlamente greiflich zu machen, aber das hat nicht, das hat mit allen ähm,
Variante nicht funktionier.
Warum ist das nicht machbar.
Sobald du Teas hast, kannst du die Umleitung nicht mehr machen über DNS.
Ja, die haben doch ihre eigene CA.
Ja, das stimmt. Das wäre dann, das werde dann tatsächlich der nächste Schritt, aber ich, ich würde mal hoffen, dass da äh Mozilla und Co ähm dann kurz Prozess machen.
Also erstens das und zweitens, wenn die Ehe von Anfang an umleiten, gibt's auch kein TLS, ne? Also ähm.
Das denke ich auch.
Du kannst ja einfach also du könntest ja TLS abschalten, leitest um auf leitest, antwortest ohnehin nur auf HTTP,
Und auf HCTP gibst du diese, gibst halt diese äh Dingenszeit.
Schilder raus.
Dann gibt es noch ähm hier wie heißt das Hard, Hypertextrail, Stricktrends for Policy, wenn die Leute also schon mal da waren,
dein Browser, also du kannst quasi im im Heada, in einem Hard-TTP Heada sagen, wenn du schon mal einmal hier,
Per TLS war's, dann kommst du nie wieder auf irgendwo auf dieser Domän hin ohne,
HTPS, was eine sehr schöne äh eine sehr schöne Lösung ist. Dann kannst du, du kannst sogar noch die deine Fingerprints, deine Zertifikatierprints ähm.
Also was einmal gesehen wurde erschwert es unter Umständen solche Seiten zu sehen, aber wir wissen ja auch davon äh hängt's ja am Ende nicht ab. Die sind ja sozusagen froh, wenn wenn sie überhaupt äh was gesperrt bekommen. Das muss ja nicht hübsch aussehen.
Also prinzipiell könnten kann man es gibt,
Möglichkeiten, da so 'ne Sperrseite hin zu machen, aber.
In dem Moment sind wir aber deutlich über DNS hinaus. Also das das ist das ist ja dann das sind schon ein großer Sprung, aber ja völlig einverstanden, ja.
Das ist High Jacking. So auf jeden Fall und wenn und dann haben wir halt wieder die alte Diskussion, ne? In dem Moment, wo so eine Infrastruktur halt steht, dann äh wird sie sicherlich nur, nicht nur auf Killspiel, äh Plattformen äh zum Einsatz kommen, ne.
Es wurde es wurde hoch und heilig versprochen, dass es das Einzige sei,
dennoch haben wir bereits die Nest und die nächsten Gesetze, die die kommen. Also es ist aktuell gibt es ähm freiwillige äh Sperren von von den Providern für auf Seite mit verbotenen,
Partner Kashi. Das soll verpflichtend werden. Das ist jetzt auch bereits die Gesetzesentwürfe sind da.
Warte mal, was ist denn verbotene Pornografie.
Porno Café, harte Pornokaffe.
Ja, harter, wie ist das so definiert? Also.
Mit ich weiß es nicht, genau, ich ich vermute mit Tieren mit Gewaltdarstellung und mit mit Kinder.
Entschuldigung, du hast dich gefragt habe. Ja okay, gut, also es gibt da auf jeden Fall eine eine Kategorisierung gesetzlicher äh Weise. Okay.
Ja. Und das dritte ist ein Urheiterrecht,
soll und auch entsprechend. Es sind auch entsprechende Netzsperren vorgesehen, aber das ist das Gesetz, das noch,
am weitesten weg ist, aber das kommt wahrscheinlich auch ziemlich bald.
Ja, das ist ja dann der Klassiker, ne? Ich meine, das ist ja eigentlich genau das, was ich meinte, nicht in den Moment, wo man die Infrastruktur hat, wo man dann erstmal gute äh Gründe im Mainzer haben, nämlich das Steuersystem muss gerettet werden, dann kommt man dann halt schnell hin zu wir haben jetzt hier auch ein Mittel, wo man äh Seitenschnell mal runternehmen kann
wenn da ein Urheberrechtsverstoß vorliegt und äh Urheberrechtsverstöße liegen ja heutzutage auch schon vor, wenn äh jemand mal irgendwas äh zitiert, was jemand anderes gesagt hat, Leaks et cetera
und ja, dann wird's halt knifflig.
Ja, darum ist es auch sehr wichtig, dass ähm jetzt eigentlich das erste Gesetz, äh was Netzsperren,
auf Gesetzesstufe eine führt, dass das ähm nicht kommt und im im Parlament ist mehr oder weniger durch, da sind jetzt noch die letzten Beratungen, die wie gesagt in diesen Tagen stattfinden, wir,
wenn's
Wenn's jetzt noch schnell geht, dann wird es tatsächlich nächste Woche verabschiedet, wenn der Kompromiss zustand,
zwischen den Reitern. Das würde bedeuten, dass wir ab Anfangs nächsten Monat,
Die Frist läuft für die Unterschrift und Sammlung, für das Referendum,
wenn's nicht ganz so schnell geht, dann wird's Dezember werden, aber das sieht jetzt so aus, wie wenn wir sehr bald wieder auf der Straße stehen würden und Unterschriften sammeln würden gegen Gesetz.
Nicht leicht.
Ja. So, kaum die frische Luft.
Immer das Positive sehen, genau.
Damit werden wir dann frische Luft brauchen ja auch unsere Zuhörenden,
Und die gibt's natürlich auch, nämlich bei unserem Tim sucht schon hektisch die Melodie. Ich versuche ja noch so ein bisschen so zu tun und da jetzt der Knopf ist und.
Bei den Terminen, da kommt die schöne Musik und äh ja wir haben wieder ein paar äh für euch und los geht's in Dresden
dort
sind vom einundzwanzigsten bis zum zweiundzwanzigsten Oktober die Datenspuren, die auch jedes Jahr stattfinden und zwar wie in den letzten Jahren auch schon,
technischen Sammlungen in Dresden, wo ich leider immer noch nicht war,
Termin kommt mir immer ein bisschen schlecht.
Du warst das schon. Genau, ich nicht, egal. Keynote äh wird gehalten von Thomas Lohninger, den Hörern dieses Podcasts natürlich bekannt äh zum Thema Netzneutralität,
Also es wird eine theatrische Lesung aus den Protokollen des NSA Untersuchungsausschusses geben unter dem Titel nicht öffentlich. Es gibt einen Junghacker äh Track ähm
da wird äh äh gelötet. Hier steht noch mein Test Station, hast du eine Ahnung, was das ist.
Nee, aber ich bin ja auch kein junger K.
Ja, ich auch nicht. Und eine Hacker-Loung.
Hackerlounge. Am Samstag.
Genau, da.
Ab achtzehn Uhr im Turmcafé das Turmcafé ist schön oben. Ja. Hm, war letztes letztes Mal auch die Hacker-Lounge. Kann man, ist schön, kann man hingehen.
Ja, ich will sehen, also gegen Abend hätte ich vielleicht sogar fast noch eine Chance, äh, dort aufzulaufen. Gibt's alles unter Datenspuren Punkt DE.
Am im vom dreiundzwanzigsten bis neunundzwanzigsten Oktober zweitausendsiebzehn findet in Wien wieder die Privacy Week statt
im Volkskundemuseum Wien.
Das Wochenticket kostet zweiundvierzig Euro, das Tagesticket dreiundzwanzig Euro mit anderen Worten, man ist natürlich mit dem Wochenticket
sehr viel besser bedient und kann dann da die gesamte Privacy Week äh besuchen. Engel werden auch noch gebraucht. Also, dreiundzwanzigster bis neunundzwanzigster Oktober Wien mit einem bunten Programm.
Ja und wer es bis nach Wien nicht äh schafft, der kann ja auf der hier bereits schon mal äh erwähnten Subscribe neun auftauchen. Da geht's rund um Podcasting und wir haben jetzt auch die äh Tickets online, Tickets Punkt Subscribe Punkt DE
noch sind welche zu haben, aber ist schon ganz gute Nachfrage. Wer also Lust hat, da dabei zu sein, kann ich nur sehr empfehlen.
Datum und Ort.
Ist dann der siebenundzwanzigste bis neunundzwanzigste Oktober in München im bayrischen Rundfunk, in den Konferenzräumen.
Siebenundzwanzigster bis dreißigster zwölfter habt ihr alle keine Zeit, da ist nämlich der vierunddreißig C drei, der vierunddreißigste
KOS Communication Congress in Leipzig. Da hat sich jetzt der CFP eröffnet. Wir suchen Einreichung in den Themenbereichen Art and Culture, Effic, Society, Anpolitics, Hardware Making, Security,
Science und neu Resilience. Ähm alles unter Events CCDE,
zu schauen, betrachtet und beachtet bitte auch den Leitfaden zur Einreichung um eine hochqualitative Einreichung anzufertigen, die es dann auch in das finale Programm schafft.
Da weiß man dann auch, was was es bedeutet in Resilienz einzureichen.
Resilienz. Das ist, Entschuldigung, wir haben ja hier nur intelligentes Publikum, die wissen ja wohl was Resilienz heißt.
Ja, aber die Moderatoren sind ja bekloppt, also erklär mal.
Welche Moderatoren sind bekloppt? Ach so, Resilienz, äh wie Widerstandsfähigkeit, Widerstandsfähigkeit.
Ja gut, ich weiß schon was Resilienz heißt, aber warum was erwartet man sich sozusagen äh.
Zukunft. Nicht patchen, sondern mal wirklich Probleme an der Wurzel lösen. So lese ich die Trackbeschreibung.
Allright? Na gut. Dann klickt mal los.
Schaue ich gerade mal, jetzt habe ich äh ja Belastbarkeit, Widerstandsfähigkeit, Stabilität etwas stabil zu bauen.
Okay. Das bringt uns ans Ende. Kira.
Kira, wen willst du denn am Sonntag? Der einzige, der hier wählen darf, bin ich, Freunde.
Ja, wir danken dir für dein für das Update aus dem aus dem schweizerischen Nachbarland.
Sehr gerne und vielen Dank.
Und ähm haben wir noch irgendwas zu sagen? Geht, geht wählen.
Ja geht wählen, weil letztes Mal schon gesagt.
Ach so, ne, dann dann jetzt nicht mehr.
Ja wählt äh wählt einfach was. Ja, wählt vor allem nicht nicht. Es ist nicht wählenfähig, irgendwie ungeil,
Das fände ich jetzt so ein bisschen frustrierend, wenn's auf einmal auch nochmal so eine riesige Nicht-Wähler-Quote äh ist, ne.
Der äh es gab äh,
Debatte in der letzten Woche in Deutschland, also in den,
in den Kolumnen darüber, ob denn nun, ob man jetzt eine,
eine Randgruppenpartei wählen,
oder nicht, also Randgruppenpartei im Sinne von schafft die Fünf-Prozent-Hürde mit an Sicherheitsgrenzen der Wahrscheinlichkeit nicht.
Ähm wurde mathematisch in der Regel überzeugend dargestellt, dass eine Stimme für eine Partei, die nicht die Fünf-Prozent-Hürde schafft,
effektiv eine Stimme für die AfD. Eine Stimme ist die der AfD zugute kommt,
Und da gibt's natürlich dann immer wieder die Debatte, ja. Äh heißt das, ich soll jetzt hier entgegen meiner Überzeugung wählen, ne? Ist eine schöne äh ein immer wieder auftretender Konflikt, dass gesagt wird, ja gut, ihr redet mir hier aus, die Partei zu wählen, von der ich wirklich,
möchte, dass sie regiert, ja? Oder die, die ich für richtig halte.
Dieters repräsentiert, was was mir wichtig ist. Sagen wir es mal so.
Genau, die genau, das ist sehr schön. Und dass dann gesagt wird, das ist ja ein perverses System, wenn es das von mir verlangt und deswegen ist das alles falsch und ähm,
das würde ich jetzt mal vorsichtig sagen, ja, das ist eine berechtigte Kritik, die kann man,
Vier Jahre lang vorbringen und verfolgen,
Aber manchmal ist man eben auch auf dem Boden der Tatsachen und muss sich überlegen, welche Konsequenz hat meine Handeln? Und ich sehe das immer, also ich man muss sich zumindest fragen, ist äh ist es das wert.
Das richtige Leben im Falschen zu führen, wenn es dann zu den falschen Konsequenzen führt und ich das vorher weiß. Ist eine, ist eine Grundsatzfrage, die man sie, die man sich stellen muss,
Ähm,
die in der Öffentlichkeit sehr gut oder sehr ausführlich in den letzten Wochen debattiert wurde. Kann man sich ja mal auf Spiegel online äh die die Beispiele durchlesen. In der TAZ gab's da Beispiele.
Oder Rechenbeispiele.
Beispiele, also ich glaube in der Tats wurde groß gesagt hier wer,
Insbesondere entzündet sich das natürlich an der Partei, ne? Der der Partei die Partei und ähm,
In der in der Tatz wurde großargumentiert, okay, eine Stimme für die Partei kommt ja, kommt effektiv nur der AfD zugute, niemand sonst. Ähm insofern wählt nicht die Partei,
wählt nur nicht die AfD und wählt am besten jemand der über die Fünf-Prozent-Hürde kommt und dann wurde glaube ich von der Margarete Stockowski auf,
Spiegel online äh dagegen gehalten. Allerdings nicht mit äh mathematischen Beispielen, sondern mit,
ähm Geisteswissenschaftlichen Beispielen. Würde ich's mal so sagen.
Ja und ich meine auch.
Muss man eine Entscheidung treffen.
Auch rein mathematisch ist das äh sozusagen auch nicht zu halten. Also ich meine, wenn ich jetzt die Partei, die Partei, die Partei wähle, ja oder irgendeine andere Mikapartei so,
dann geht das sehr wohl erstmal von dem Anteil der AfD ab. Das ist so.
Äh die Fünf-Prozent-Hürde ist.
Unabhängig von der Fünf-Prozent-Hürde, aber wenn kleine Parteien Zweitstimmen bekommen, sinkt der Wahlanteil der AfD, von den abgegebenen Stimmen. So, das ist einfach so.
Nein, nein, da darf die Fünf-Prozent-Hürde verteilt, aber am Ende die Stimmen unter denen, die.
Es bezieht sich auf die Sitze.
Ich rede jetzt erstmal nur von dem Anteil so und der Anteil reduziert sich und zwar bei allen reduzierte sich. Wenn du jetzt irgendwie zehn die Partei die Partei hast, so die alle vier Komma neun Prozent bekommen, ja?
Dann sparen wir am Ende Geld, weil weniger Leute im Bundestag sitzen oder was ist dein Argument?
Nein, dann kriegen die anderen halt auch, dann dann sinkt natürlich auch äh äh der relative Anteil,
der anderen. So und dann wird's halt klar, dann dann zählt's irgendwie wie die Sitzverteilung ist, aber es ist halt äh durchaus möglich, äh den Stimmanteil, den die AfD hat, zum Beispiel unter fünf Prozent zu bringen.
Weil die Stimmen, die sie bekommen, halt einfach nicht mehr so einen hohen Gesamtanteil haben, ja? Also du kannst.
Ja, aber das ist unwahrscheinlich, das ist passiert.
Unwahrscheinlich. Ja, aber mit Wahrscheinlichkeiten zu argumentieren halte ich für schwierig.
Den Anteil der AfD unter fünf Prozent kriegen wir folgendermaßen hin. Alle die AfD wohl wählen wollen wählen bitte was anderes.
Und alle, die nicht AfD wählen wollen, wählen bitte.
Ja
So, relativ einfach.
Mehr konnten wir nicht tun.
Ich hab extra diese Debatte kann man sich mal anschauen so oder so glaub ich beide sagen willst du.
Werden wir auch überleben. Alles.
Leute, jetzt ist Schluss hier. Wir haben eine verfahrene Sendung heute hier. Kire nochmal vielen Dank äh für deinen Beitrag.
Danke, ich bin Fauls.
Und äh ja, jetzt schalten wir wieder zurück in ins Wahlstudio.
Danke auch an Markus Peter und eine weitere anonyme Person. Ciao, ciao.
Bis dann, ciao ciao.